it's always handy to catch a unicorn on
radio so if you uh if you're out there
and you love your time share call in the
phone number is triple eight eight two
five five
two two five when i started this radio
show 30 years ago uh we set out to do
the same thing we do today and that was
help you
we want you to win we want you to get
out of debt become prosperous be
unreasonably generous outrageously
generous we don't want you to get ripped
off and so anything that is ripping you
off has become my enemy over the years
and the more it rips you off the more
vocal i am about it and the more that
industry hates me i mean literally hates
me uh and so for instance when i go off
on payday lenders which i do frequently
because they're absolute scum they take
advantage of and oppress the poor 800
interest if you're a payday lender your
grandmother should be ashamed of you
your mother should be ashamed of you i'm
ashamed of you you should stop it
you're ripping people off if you're a
whole life agent you should stop it if
you lease cars you should stop it if you
sell timeshares for god's sakes go get a
good job
leave so joining me for this hour for a
couple of segments are some folks from a
company called the newton group gordon
newton is with us he's the president and
founder of the norton group newton group
he has been helping people with
timeshares get out of timeshare since
2003 so about the last two decades he's
watched this scummy industry evolve and
his head legal counsel with their
private law firm michelle cumberland is
with us as well to address this from a
legal standpoint to make sure that
gordon and i stay in the in the road
welcome you two good to have you thanks
for having us dave appreciate it and
thanks for fighting the fight on behalf
of people who can't stand up to this
billion dollar
industry
yeah out of control yeah you know people
need help uh it's uh they don't have to
go it alone uh you know and i tell
people they're not alone either you know
we just recently conducted a uh time
sure exit study of over 9000 surveys and
uh the results are pretty shocking
yeah i mean we we actually did some
research with ramsey research team here
it wasn't as large as sample size as you
did and we gathered up ours was not ours
was more of a survey and yours was more
of a study so yours has got better
research technique to it and more in
depth but i mean the thing that you find
97
of time share owners surveyed said they
experienced deceptive trade practices
what industry stays open when 97 out of
100 people say they tried to screw me
how does this work well you know i'll
tell you it's uh
this isn't a group uh survey these
people take this take take the questions
at home individually and you know what
have been shocking had
you know fifty percent of it came back
and said you know what we experienced uh
lies and unfair sales practices
fifty percent would have been a lot
97
is really shocking and there is a
problem there and it stems from how
these things are sold
one of the uh attorneys that we talked
to in the industry calls it legalized
fraud well and uh that's his words and i
kind of like them and so um you know but
but as we you know you go through the
study and you understand
how deceptive this is and then how stuck
people are
uh by the way if you guys want to see a
copy of the study just go to
timesharetruth.com
and you can see the study of 9 000
actual timeshare owner
experiences
in case you're
having a weak moment
george campbell and you you might want
to go and visit a timeshare place in
order to get a free vacation
don't
go get in the tiger cage now if you
don't know what the tiger cage is this
is something i dreamed up i just made it
up because it's a metaphor but if you
ever go in one of these pressure tactics
things where they lock you in a room and
won't let you out until you buy their
time share in order to get free tickets
to the water park in order to get a free
stay at their little half butt hotel
that they call a condo and um it's just
nasty and basically it's like saying to
going to the zoo and the zookeeper says
the zoo manager says if you will go in
the tiger cage and sit with the tiger
for one hour we will give you free zoo
passes for a year however i need to warn
you that the tiger's not been fed in a
week and a half and he likes
people meat he wants to eat you and you
say oh for free zoo tickets i can manage
the tiger and you go sit with the tiger
for an hour well most people get eaten
that's what amounts to they come out of
it and michelle by the time they get in
ural's office
and they're talking to you about the
legal aspects of this you start to hear
how bottled up and pressured they were
oh i do and and from a legal perspective
you know the problem really starts from
the very beginning with that legal
binding contract i'd like to invite you
know those people that have a points
membership with a time share to go
actually look at their contract it'll
say on there i purchase let's say 15 000
points but it doesn't tell you anything
in the contract of what you're getting
for those points it doesn't say that you
get a one bedroom that you can go at
this time of year or that you can have a
rental car with your points or instead
what it says
is you're buying 15 000 points
the terms of how you can use these
points are in some external document you
agree to bind yourself to that external
document and oh by the way we can amend
it whenever we want to
and so we hear all the time clients
coming in and say i was told that i
could use my points to pay my
maintenance fees or i could use my
points to uh get a rental car or i could
go any time of the year i wanted to go
or i could go to a different location or
whatever exactly all of that turns out
to be a lie as soon as they call the
resort and try to make those types of
reservations and use their points in
that manner they're told oh our terms
have changed
and oh guess what according to your
contract you're bound to whatever
amendments they make and that's why it's
so difficult for attorneys like me to
bring those claims of fraudulent
inducement and misrepresentations
because what's the court going to say
well what's in the four corners of your
document what's in your contract does it
say in your contract that you can use
points for maintenance fees does it say
well the sales agent told me i could do
that
well but it doesn't say it in your
contract so let me ask you something i'm
just curious i mean give me a 30 second
answer because it's just i just got
curious from my old business law class
that i took back when the dinosaurs
roamed the earth a contract that
references
something outside the contract that can
be unilaterally changed how is something
that can be unilaterally changed by the
by one party in other words another
party doesn't have to have get
permission how is that a binding
contract so one of the things that we
can do in the united states is we can
contract just about anything right and
so in your contract it actually says
these are the documents that govern the
terms of your agreement and you agree
and understand that we can amend these
so we get everything including your
money and we decide what we're going to
give you and you're signing and you're
agreeing to that exactly just to get out
of the tiger's cage absolutely and it's
completely binding in that regard it is
and so it makes it very difficult for
attorneys like myself when a client
comes in and says i was bold face lied
to and i want you to do something about
it
but unfortunately if it's not written in
the contract it's very difficult for us
to bring those claims that's what he
said she said
yeah and
now we're arguing with the timeshare
salesman who you can tell they were
lying if their mouth was moving
oh my gosh the newton group joins me uh
as part of our timeshare suck theme hour
gordon newton michelle cumberland
and we'll be answering your questions
and taking your calls about timeshare so
go ahead and call in now triple eight
eight two five five two two five this is
the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
we're doing a time shares suck theme
hour
[Music]
just because i believe in clarity so we
want you to understand exactly what
we're talking about here
stay away from them avoid them if you
haven't then you need to try to exit is
what it's called in the timeshare world
exiting a timeshare is very difficult
many of the companies have been run out
of business by the time share business
by the billion dollar timeshare industry
suing and suing and suing and suing and
suing and the legal fees just run them
out of business
even if they're successful exiting
people uh a company that's been around
since 2003 is the newton group
and their their website if you want to
read the study
results that they have 9 000 people that
they study that are actual time share
owners and their experiences you can get
it at
timesharetruth.com timesharetruth.com
if you're stuck in a time share and you
want out
they may be able to help you they may
not be able to help you some of these
situations are different than other
they're all different than each other
and some of them are easier to
uh convince the timeshare company to let
you go let my people go
uh or and some of them are dead near
impossible so no promises but check out
what they do their business model
and how they work with the law firm the
partner law firm that's filed numerous
lawsuits and arbitration demands on
behalf of timeshare clients also at
timesharetruth.com
now so the industry
uh
gordon has in my mind i i've watched
hilton by diamond and run mikey off uh
mikey flasky was the
the head timeshare salesman there he and
i got into it on twitter several times
yeah guy's a scumburger and um i just
don't want to be unclear today um but
the um
but but you know hilton now is in the
business big time
um we were a little shocked they
actually closed on that deal because
they generally are pretty good company
but they have really brought in a barrel
of fish hooks there then you know we've
got the uh queen of versailles david uh
was his last name david
c siegel siegel yeah that that mess
um and uh um that whole i mean
these guys some of the things the the
sophistication of it has evolved
and the way that they sell it and even
their legal documentation has evolved
over the 20 years hasn't it
yeah you know i mean
just in the in the consumer's got a loan
you know and you can see this too
michelle referenced it earlier you know
you're not just agreeing to the terms
that might be in that 15-page contract
they often reference other agreements
um you know this isn't this is just an
example taken from one public offering
statement again this is in the
consumer's guide you can see it yourself
but it literally says
that weeks are offered for sale for
personal use and enjoyment only and
should not be purchased by any
prospective purchaser for resale or as
an investment opportunity or with any
expectation of achieving rental income
capital appreciation or any financial
return or valuable benefit
that's how these things have no value
and we set it in the consumer guide well
that would be nice to know right when
you went in or even a part of that
contract but this is something that's
this is language that's taken from a
public offering statement that's 249
pages in link yeah and the consumer's
not going to read that when he's in the
tiger cage
no no he just signs it just anything let
me out of here right
so uh michelle what is the
the times that you're able to be
successful
uh getting someone out exiting them what
is the uh is is it trade secret to tell
how you do that or what is involved or
uh who has a better chance of getting
out or who doesn't uh what are those
what are the situations
that you're the most that you have the
highest probability of being able to
exit them
so from a legal perspective it's always
about that legal binding contract right
what does that contract say
does it have a default provision does it
have a term
once we identify what the rights and
obligations are for the individual then
we may have um
some negotiating power with the resort
we may be able to say or to the
developer or the association depending
on see this is another thing people
don't understand you're not just dealing
with just the timeshare entity you're
also dealing with an owner's association
you're dealing with the holder of
whoever
of the note who financed the loan you
could potentially be dealing with a
management company that's running the
resort i mean it's it's really this one
consumer against
five different entities sometimes um so
it also depends on who we're negotiating
with if we're just negotiating
negotiating with the owners association
and it's a paid in full
that probably will be a little bit
easier for us than if we're also dealing
with a holder of a note and a debt
collector and a management company and
so it each individual situation you know
it's based on their specific facts yeah
and so if they have debt against it it's
harder because you've got to get the
debt forgiven right so you really have
to have them on fraud or the proposal
that they have committed fraud in some
way for them to release all of that
either we have some tool that we can use
from a negotiating perspective or
sometimes these resorts will
allow a voluntary surrender but of
course there's usually some payment
involved in that you know they want some
kind of money to take these things back
in their inventory
but even once we get the the individual
out of the time share it doesn't really
stop there i mean we really need to get
their credit report looked at a lot of
these
timeshare lenders are incorrectly
reporting to the credit bureau sometimes
they're issuing tax documents 1099s to
98. we need to take a look at those and
make sure that they're properly
reporting any canceled debt to the irs i
mean there is a lot involved
um but if there's no cancelled debt if i
pay 10 000 cash or 20 000 cash
for a time share
and i want to get out of it
just to get rid of the fees you give up
the money that you spent that's
absolutely that's just yeah i never
typically am never able to get money
back without some type of um like we
were just successful in an arbitration
and getting a full refund but it was
because i could actually prove fraud we
actually had the handwritten notes
of the uh individual's uh sales agent so
i was actually able to prove fraud but
that's very unusual and very rare yeah
that agent got fired i'm sure he did sir
so um you know it really depends on
the individual situation what evidence i
have and whether i have somebody on the
other side of the table that's willing
to negotiate with me
tom share owners have to say in their
own words a large number of documents
were placed in front of us we were not
allowed to take the paperwork back to
our room to review it further about
making a decision additionally we were
not allowed to consult anyone other than
the resort representative at the sales
meeting regarding the contents of the
document they're trapped in the tiger
tiger cage that's a standard trip deal
in this world today consumers are so
aware i am shocked that these kinds of
practices are still effective but they
are very effective well they are and
again because you know you will spend
anywhere between two to six hours with
that individual right because you can't
get away from them well you know they're
they're friendly folk too you know i
mean you're there talking with them all
day and by the end of it you know a lot
of our consumers have
told us that they were just worn down
and they were willing to sign just just
to get out of there um you know these
these are you know that statement you
just read that's from a uh
uh
that that person is willing to testify
under oath under penalty of perjury uh
that's from a declaration we've got
hundreds of declarations from these
people as well too
telling us their timeshare truth this
isn't me telling you this this is the
voice of the american timeshare owner
that's what you're hearing that's we're
hearing through the study and that's
we're here to help so the message we
want to get to you from the newton group
and from the ramsey organization
uh before these two step off the set
here is a don't buy a timeshare
period there are no circumstances none
but which is economically comes out to
your benefit you are signing up for
god only knows what and you're probably
not going to get it and you're going to
get stuck and you're legally bound and
you're signing ridiculous documents that
are one-sided and you're getting screwed
so just avoid the entire industry like
the plague number two if you are stuck
in a time share there are no
magic pills there is no easy way out but
sometimes if you have the handwritten
notes of the agent that committed fraud
uh then
that one was a rare one i would love to
open in the room when that happened but
uh uh but if you've got stuff like that
or if you've got a way that you can do
that sometimes they can real people like
the newton group can really help you the
timeshare exit business is shrinking uh
again a lot of the players have been
driven out of business a lot of the
attorneys that have done this for a
living have been sued to the point they
have been run out of business newton
group is standing
has been since 2003 visit their website
if you need some help with this or if
you just want to read the exit study
results timesharetruth.com
timesharetruth.com thanks for dropping
by you two
thanks for having us
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today he's also the host of the
fine print
on ramsey networks our latest podcast
series first season in the books where
you read the fine print you don't get
into trouble which means that uh the
next season of the fine print will
definitely have a timeshare
or six episodes i was just gonna say it
might take a whole season just to get
through it all my gosh there's so much
there's so much fine print problems and
the lack of fine print too if you have a
time share story a timeshare nightmare
story or maybe you just love your
timeshare it's okay we'll talk to you
too we might make fun of your face we'll
do it in good nature just because we
love you but um we help people that make
mistakes all the time here and
the phone number is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
now george has dove in and in the last
five minutes done in-depth research on
the values that time shares hold yeah
five minutes worth of research it took
me two seconds i went to ebay went to
completed and sold listings and i found
many many time shares that sold for one
dollar
one dollar bob one dollar bob and so if
that doesn't tell you it's a bad
investment i don't know what does i paid
10 000 i sold it for a dollar that's how
i got rich i not an investing guru i
bought him for 25 000
and i never got to stay there for a
sense of ownership and i got but i have
i had i but i just knew that i just knew
if i signed these documents that they
would at least let me leave so instead
of falling for the pitch just go to ebay
if you want one that badly just go to
ebay and pay a dollar there you go
there's a money hack for you today so i
wonder if you could what if we could
figure out a way
to get the emails or the text numbers of
the people that are in the tiger cage
while they're in there with a sales
person that goes
you can buy this for a dollar
i should stand outside and pitch it to
them yeah it's an even get a little sign
get a little signing you can do one of
those spin signs george
one dollar time share your one dollar
time share is here folks
goodness
your career is just going down the tubes
here you know that
i'm not surprised i had a good run
oh timeshare exit stories or timeshare
problems here at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five
brown says the high pressure sales
tactics used to convince us to buy more
points were exhausting and mind-numbing
it seemed to us that the process was
designed to wear us down so we would
give in just to get out
of the
presentation wow also known as the tiger
cage that's one strategy yeah just sign
everything just i want to go home
i promise i'll never come back i'll
never use the time share i just want to
give you money let me go oh my god how
bad does the situation have to be
mike is in sacramento tell us your time
share story mike
guys great to be here appreciate it sure
what's up uh so
yeah we uh i never bought a time share
but my my
future bride bought a time share before
i met her so i like to tease her about
that so
be careful be careful she may remain
future a long time you keep this up i
don't i know you got to trade carefully
but so she was to give you the backstory
she was 22 years old at the time she
went into the lion's cage and the tiger
cage and she ended up buying a timeshare
for
about 17 000 bucks at the time it was um
i think it was trend west which now is
world mark or wyndham or whoever it is
so
five years fast forward five years later
is when we met
and i had a lot of experience with time
shares because my dad had gone to these
presentations he was a pastor he had
five kids and he loved disney world so
he would always go to these
presentations to get free tickets to
disney world so but he was he was a rock
star in the sense that he never ever
bought one of these things so i kind of
had a front row seat to see how these
companies operated and everything that
you hear on these things is absolutely
true with the tactics and everything but
so i heard she had a time share big red
flag i'm like oh man we gotta look at
this so
i'm the i'm the finance guy of the
family so i sat down and did the math so
basically
they had financed everything she'd have
any money she's a first-year teacher so
she's making maybe 27 20 grand a year
16 interest on all that on the loan for
the 17k right so it's like a high
interest credit card and they had to do
a down payment she didn't have any money
for the down payment oh it's no problem
we can finance that part too
so basically
when you do the math on this so five
years in if you finance a down payment
is it a down payment
exactly right exactly
so her her point system
allowed her about four nights a year
more or less and she never really used
it because her system
you had to be
you can't book it more than 30 days out
so the people that had the higher
systems could book first and then that
left nothing for her right so
but assuming that she was able to use
four nights so four nights a year for
five years that's 20 nights right she
spent 16k so that works out 800
800
a night right is the average of what
this thing actually costs when you
factor in the maintenance fees and the
payment and the interest so i
immediately went into full blow i'm
about to make you throw up right this
makes me sick so
i try to get rid of this thing and as we
all know just like you guys said a
second ago you can't give these things
away i put it on ebay i put it on
craigslist i tried to give away to some
friends and that's the thing though dave
like i couldn't they're not friends
anymore
i couldn't get it in good conscience i
couldn't give it away because i'm giving
away this crappy product like you i
couldn't do it so
so they always tout these things as like
the stress-free vacations right when you
own these timeshares so we paid it off
we put it on our debt snowball i'm like
well we can't get rid of it we're going
to pay off the balance right paid it off
as quickly as we could so now we own the
thing
and we would use it every once in a
while but
they call it the stress-free like it's a
vacation you own it you're like kind of
a big shot right to use all these words
and they're selling this to you but
every time you go to check into one of
these places
it's the opposite of stress-free this is
the most stressful experience that i've
ever had because you check in you get
your you get your key everybody's super
nice and in most hotels that would be
the end of it right you go to your room
and you go on your vacation but in this
place you'd have to get your key and
then they say oh
uh wait a minute you can't you can't
leave that you have to go talk to the
goober across the hall who's got your
parking pass right so you
bring your luggage across the hall back
into the tiger cage
tiger cage and he's this guy's your best
friend right oh where are you guys from
what are you gonna do here uh oh
you guys aren't gonna believe this we
have a free breakfast so you guys
qualify for it so why don't you just
come to the free breakfast did you bring
friends with you oh you did perfect your
friends can come to the free breakfast
did that i mentioned it was free they'd
say free free for rate all these free
words oh you don't want to go okay well
i got free tickets for you for whatever
you want to do oh that's not good enough
how about we give you 150 bucks and so
the first time you do it you're like oh
okay
it's an owner update right that's how
they tout it it's an owner
it's an owner update upgrade
we update upgrades
exactly they say we're going to tell you
how to best use your vacation and of
course as we all know you go in there
and all it is is a high pressure sales
tactic where well that's what i want
someone to do is tell me how to best use
my vacation wow
george i should tell you how to best use
your vacation you do a good job whitney
would whitney would like that she would
like me telling you how to best use your
vacation you're a good salesman dave we
might fall for it i'm not that good yeah
well the best one was when we didn't go
one of the guys this was like the final
straw one of the guys told my wife i
couldn't i couldn't go to these i
couldn't even talk to the parking pass
guy anymore so that would get so upset
right so i i would wait in the car that
was the stress-free part of your
vacation yeah when you got upset in the
car
but he told she told my wife that she
was being an irresponsible time share
owner by not going to the owner update
right and she like flew down the papers
and walked away and i i saw her do this
you know what i'm an irresponsible hoa
member because i refuse to go to the
meetings and watch the drama on those
things that's no vacation right
yeah
so i'm one of the few i'm one of the
rare rare few so we owned it for 20
years so she bought him she's 22 or 42
now
it ended up being i did the math on this
too the total time using it
it cost us 429 a night if you average it
all out right which is still not
counting the time you took to calculate
this
you're worth more than that mike
yeah
so
oh man so but the the silver lining and
again i'm one of the few there was some
it was it was buried in the website
somewhere where they had a uh an exit
they had a way out i'm like oh whatever
i'll try to do it and truth be told jim
credit they did let me out after 20
years it wasn't
after 20 years
out of prison
generous of them i'm just saying we got
all we're going to get out of this guy
after 20 years so
he did his time in the prison he finally
let him out i did my time i did my time
your honor i'm probably my time
uh
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
an 81 year old man claims in court that
diamond resorts international a
timeshare club defrauded him of fifty
thousand dollars and keeps trying to get
more
lewis wolfe claims diamond resorts
international club and six affiliates
used high pressure sales tactics to open
credit cards in his name run up bills on
them before plaintiff even realized the
cards existed and charged him more than
50 thousand dollars for membership
services in diamond resort entities wolf
sue diamond resorts on march 8th in
superior court he claims the abusive
sales pitches on the phone and in person
could last for four to five
hours and despite the sales pitches
despite the fifty thousand dollars they
already took from him he says it
continued to harass him diamond
international sends buses to seniors
communities to take them to nevada and
once they get a name they will be
non-stop with the phone calls
you can't stop them yikes
this is unbelievable and they're preying
on these folks busting them from the
nursing homes or you're preying on
people who can't
who
will fold to the pressure yeah i mean
that guy talked about his dad being a
pastor and he went in there and made a
game out of it and got out of there i
just don't i don't you know one of the
things i don't put myself in places
where i have to be a butt to leave
you know i don't
i just i'm not intentionally i mean i
have been there a time or two but i
don't say i'm to go into this
confrontational thing on purpose to get
something for free
just to
it's not worth it to me it's the it's um
i mean i don't mind conflict when it's
useful
and takes you somewhere i do conflict
for a living i'm a talk radio host come
on
so uh but but this idea that i i
i just think you're asking for it when
you walk in there and so
here's the thing you can go anywhere in
the world and stay for 800 bucks a night
yeah and shoes
and when you walk up and you're paying
800 bucks a night let me tell you what
they do
anything you want
i've stayed at 800 a night places a time
or two and they treat you
well without any upsells sales pitches
and there's nothing you know but sharon
and i and you know my
i just uh so we're playing golf in cabo
we come off the golf course and this guy
walks up to me and he goes hey senor how
are you doing hey man how you doing
so we're talking and uh he goes hey you
want to play you you want to play for
free and i said well we just finished
thank you though i appreciate it and he
said well i i can refund your your green
fees and i want you can that'd be cool
why are we doing that he goes i just
need to sit down and talk to you for a
few minutes i went oh oh
now my wife my ever cheap
wonderful
frugal wife says honey we should hear
hear what he has to say i said honey you
just if you play with snakes you will be
bitten if you go into the tiger cage you
will get eaten i just play golf i'm in
cabo life is good why do i want to screw
up this wonderful day for the re for the
cost of the round of golf if i didn't
have the money to play there i shouldn't
have been playing there hello so oh my
gosh sharon would have done it for free
just to hang out sharon would have done
it two nickels yeah but that's the and
then she gets in the tiger i see how
these people do it
because she was she was ready to
sign me up to sit and listen to boy
child
it's not happening it's just not
happening sweet little guy but i'm not
listening to it no i got i want to go
eat a taco i'm not no thank you
no thank you in four hours you could
have actually worked and just made the
money up i mean it's just insane
it's not worth it oh now wait a minute
now now you've gone to mexico i
shouldn't be encouraging people to work
for money you're right but we do have we
promised we would air in oh she hung up
did we lose him
just as i was getting ready to go to the
good time share call nancy from orange
she had a good experience and she said
she'd had a good good experience but i
guess she didn't figure we were actually
going to air it we were well i told you
if you had a good experience or a bad
experience we would air your call i
think kelly scared her off kelly it's
kelly's fault it has to be kelly's fault
everything is kelly's fault open phone
it's part of her job description triple
eight eight two five five two two five
if you have a time share
experience when karen henderson of
orlando realized the points she'd
purchased from windham
resembled a never-ending contract yeah
think she felt that enlisting in its
buy-back program would ensure she wasn't
stuck paying the increasing maintenance
fees and that her daughter wouldn't
inherit a money pit but soon enough her
owner update meetings there it is again
begin to transition from buy more
and better vacations to how to offset
your mortgage and she started dealing
with lengthy sit-downs with multiple
salespeople who she says pushed her hard
to invest in quotes
in the points
which uh we heard uh from gordon newton
a while ago in the actual buyer's
documentation the disclaimer that no one
reads it's as thick as a bible that says
this is all the ways they're going to
screw you read this and no one reads it
of course
um that you know who reads that stuff
i'm no i'm not reading that but it says
in there the points have actual no
monetary value and um we have just
screwed you and here's a here's the
documentation stating that we just
screwed you and so we want you but we
want to be real clear that this is all
legal when we screwed you and so um
it has no no economic value it doesn't
so here's the thing but do the math like
that caller a while ago from la
add up what you're spending
per
night
and go is that an 800 room
is that a 753 room
and i think you'll answer the question
and go nope that's rhetorical the answer
is always no nope
oh i stayed at a place the other day and
it was supposed to be nicer than it was
and it was just a hotel i mean it's a
nice hotel
expensive
but uh it's still i looked at it and i
went
nope
that room's not worth that and you know
what that mean you know what that means
i'm not going back there next year
because it's not worth it i looked at
the dollar and i looked at the room and
i went nope those two things don't match
so last time i'm doing this right and
you can choose next time and next and
you know what i'm not under contract to
go back there next year and the year
after and the year after and they're not
going to raise my fees and they're not
going to
reference some extraneous
uh
contract that they've changed the rules
on again to add to my deal here oh
nancy's back good we found her okay good
we want to get to nancy because nancy's
got a good timeshare experience we
should end on a positive note nancy tell
us tell us about your good timeshare
experience yes dave love your show thank
you
well we we've been pleased with ours for
15 years
i admit some of the things you've said
are very true but it's a kind of a buyer
beware thing
but
when we're all in and settled which is
usually pretty simple like checking into
a hotel um
we find it
consistently clean
love the kitchen love the space
versus staying in a motel room so it's
kind of a it's kind of a condo kind of a
condo situation yes it is where is it
and
we can use it
numerous places we've probably been to
50 locations 55 zero to it
pretty close
wow 40 to 50 we've gone
75 times i would say in the 15 years
we use it consistency consistently
and
feel like we're
you know it does go down to our daughter
which may not work so well i don't know
if she'll be so thrilled
but it's certainly better than having a
vacation home that sits empty and that
you have to maintain
we found the maintenance it is cheaper
it is cheaper than that that's true so i
since i've trashed all these other
companies what's the company so we can
at least announce a company that
someone's pleased with
it's windham oh it's windham okay
because i've already trashed them good
okay then there's one windham uh
customer that is happy nancy thank you
so much yes for calling thank you for
that positive note yes a good note i
gotta call out she said it's better than
a motel so that's the bar apparently
it's cleaner than well because you're
getting she got a kitchen and you can go
in and make coffee and it's like a
little kitchenette or a little condo or
whatever that's good but i mean
obviously she's done well with it so you
know hats off to her yeah and that's off
the window you made nancy in portland
oregon happy well done well done so uh
97 dissatisfaction according to the
study done by the newton group uh so we
found one of the three percent amazing
that's um but we can find we can find
anyone with this show this show has
unbelievable reach
i mean 22 million people we got reach we
can get to three percent we can we can
find you if you're in the three percent
nancy thank you all kidding aside i
appreciate you calling in um and telling
the truth and uh we air we told you we
would air both and we we did so
our rule of thumb as consumer advocates
watching out for your money
stay away from timeshares
real simple if you need some help or you
want to read that study go to
timesharetruth.comtimesharetruth.com
check out the newton group and they'll
give you the lineup on the deal it's
that simple this is the ramsey chef
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsay show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money it is a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five some say the advice is worth
exactly what you pay for it triple eight
eight two five five two two five it's
free
george as us george campbell as i said
uh is my co-host today he's the host of
the fine print and also the host of
entree leadership the entree leadership
podcast both podcasts are very popular
and he's here to answer questions for
you today we'll be talking to you about
your relationships about your money
about your careers
about your mental health about
everything we we weave all of it
together it's called life
and we do it right here on the ramsay
show with you every day karise is with
us in rockford illinois hi karise
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
well
um i just had a baby um new year's eve
she was born 12 weeks early
she's currently in the nicu in madison
and um
we found out that she has a rare disease
um
one in 100 100 000 children have that
disease
the congenital disease um disorder of
glycosylation
so basically the doctors don't know for
sure how long she's gonna be there um
they have to treat symptom by symptom so
i guess my question today is um
i'm a teacher i'm not sure exactly when
to go back to work um my husband and i
um are on baby step three we had saved
up
our emergency fund but we have about a
month left of it
before we are kind of out so i'm not
sure what to do when i have to be there
daily
i'm sorry
that's very hard
what does your what's your husband make
he is at 35 000 a year
so he brings in about 1800 a month
and how much vacation did you have from
teaching
um i used it all up
it was about six weeks
you're either back in the classroom or
you're without pay
yes and you need to be there with a baby
so
so yeah you're going to be with them
yeah what do you make yeah
i'm at 61 000 a year
which is about 3 500 a month yeah what's
he do
my husband is a mechanic
okay
huh
well uh you are square in the middle of
a hurricane kiddo and you knew that um
you didn't need me to tell you that um
yeah so uh
how much is your house payment
um it's 1500 a month how many other kids
have you got
we have one nine-year-old
and that is our house is our only that
we were getting ready to be on baby
steps four five and six yeah um we're
going to be doing that next so
okay so what we teach folks when they're
in a financial crisis and you're walking
towards one
um
is to take care of necessities first
and only
in your case it's first in your case
it's definitely only so um you start
making a list of things in their order
of importance
and so i'll help you foods first
keep food in the house
utilities are second keep the lights on
and house payments third
and when you finish with that you're
you are already out of money
yeah
uh with his income versus a 1500 house
payment so your burn rate's really
really fast how much you got left in the
emergency fund
um i have about a month's worth um it's
about four thousand about four thousand
dollars
okay and um
so if we keep the lights on and we eat
and we pay the house payment uh you got
to put a little gas in the car to get to
work
uh if we quit paying everything else
what would that be
um
it would probably be
we had barely anything left after that
um i know but if you don't pay anything
else there shouldn't be a lot of other
necessities bills
have you got non-necessity bills that
i'm not you don't have any debt that's
good
yeah we don't have any debt we just have
our house payment we have transportation
um we have life insurance
um and just paying the medical bills as
they come in
don't pay any medical bills
okay don't pay a medical bill right now
you can pay them later but you're not
gonna pay them right now
um because i want to keep the money for
food lights and shelter
and car gas
and make it last as long as i can make
it last there
um and then we've got to think about and
i don't know george have you got any
ideas on what we can do to get some
income coming in are you a member of a
good church in the area
yes we are okay i'd let your pastor know
with a need and see if they can't raise
some money for you guys just to keep you
afloat okay you know you don't need they
have done that a little bit for us um to
help us get back and forth to madison
because it's about an hour and a half
drive
so that's been very helpful we have
really kind people around us no that's
good okay because i mean ten thousand
dollars changes this whole situation
dramatically
yeah
uh twenty thousand dollars changes it a
lot you don't need a hundred yeah
no to turn the corner here because you
got insurance to cover nicu and you've
got medical bills that'll pile up and
you can get to the medical bills later
when you get back to a hundred thousand
dollar income when you're back in the
classroom
right okay
so fundraising is one thing comes to
mind the other thing that comes to mind
is um
you guys may have to figure out uh
where can we get income and it sounds to
me like he's working extra to me
yeah he does he gets all the side jobs
he can yeah okay and even able to go to
madison twice a week
are you both going or is it just one of
you
um i'm going seven days a week he's just
going um on the weekends um when he's
off of work what do you teach
um i teach sixth grade science okay have
you got the bandwidth emotionally i
wouldn't
but do you have the bandwidth
emotionally take on a couple of kids to
tutor at 25 bucks an hour um
possibly um mentally i'm not sure if i'm
ready to go back to the classroom right
now don't want you going in the
classroom i'm just saying i'm just
saying if you took two kids
a week for two hours that'd be a couple
hundred bucks a week
that's true
but it's if you can do it i i truthfully
i can't breathe and this is i don't even
know you but i mean
little babies in nicu just puts my
puts yeah my stomach in my throat i just
um
yeah and you guys are really facing some
real challenges and so i don't want to
be unkind or anything and this is not
just you need to go get an extra job
dude you know that's not what i'm saying
at all i get it i i don't know if you
can do that but i'm just trying to keep
you afloat because if you can keep the
basics going if you if you could come
out of this and all you got some pile of
medical bills
and you're behind on a couple of odds
and ends
because you got just enough in to
supplement his income and keep the house
payment paid and lights and water and
food
you you know you're going to be set up
to turn this around financially really
quick
yeah we will too we just don't we just
didn't want to get we just don't want to
go backwards so i want you to stay on
top of it because it's easy to stick
your head in the sand during these times
and um we'll be praying for you if you
need anything you call us we'll help you
any way we can here okay
okay thanks dave thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
still on baby step number one
how'd you guess with health care costs
rising learn how christian healthcare
ministries can help you make the most
out of your budget visit
chministries.org
budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
on the phone in dallas texas is logan
and
aaron i'm sorry aaron is with us and i'm
here to do a debt-free scream according
to my screen how much have you guys paid
off
hey we paid off 119
424 dollars way to go how long did this
take
um right at 24 months good for you and
your range of income during that time
um we started about 58 000 went up to
135 and now we're about
95 000.
cool good for you very good so what do
you guys do for a living
i'm a
full-time firefighter
i'm a trauma icu nurse
oh wow very good what kind of debt was
your 119 000
well unfortunately we were very normal
so it was
we we had
we had both of us had student loan debts
that we that we kept putting off so we
had a bunch of interest with that we had
two vehicles we had medical debt a
family loan
a lawn mower
oh how much you own your lawnmower we i
owed um 3500 a lawnmower that's not as
bad as i've heard so i'm i'm i'm glad
that's still it's still like i mean as
much as i borrowed from my first car but
yeah nothing no no big deal but yeah oh
my god
how long have you all been married
we've been married uh ten years this
past december so what happened two years
ago that put you on this ramsey journey
um well um again unfortunately so when
we got married um so like i said 10
years ago my father-in-law came to us
and uh or whenever i asked him to marry
aaron he said you've got to do two
things for me he said you need to love
the lord god with all your heart body
and soul and you've got to go through
financial peace
yes sir yes sir and the um uh
unfortunate part is he uh he forgot to
say that we had to do what the lessons
taught so that was assumed
so we kind of forgot that part no box
checking we actually have to implement
yeah okay you were davish oh not even
yeah you just went you just did anything
to get the girl i got i know what you're
doing all right yes sir that's right so
we ended up um in october of 19 uh i was
going back and forth to uh uh to dallas
we live a little east of dallas and
had a pretty good commute so i started
listening to the show again
and it was that point of i was stressed
out we had two car payments
aaron wasn't working at that time
i was absolutely stressed out and
it was just one of those i've
sick and tired of being sick and tired
i've had enough and i came back and
talked to aaron that evening i was like
hey we've been doing this wrong this
whole time let's
let's finally do it and she was at like
you know god was putting on my heart to
let's do this again too and it was game
on after that wow so what did you guys
do did you go back through fpu read a
book what kind of get you back on track
and motivated
so i have a copy of financial peace and
i read that again
and then we got we did get go through or
get ramsey plus again
went through the lessons our church was
putting on the class
at the time so we also got plugged in
with that
i jumped on the facebook group
which was really awesome just because we
were able to get encouragement get
feedback see other people's
you know questions and stuff and that
that was really motivational for us
in getting through that two-year grind
so the ramsey baby steps facebook group
yes sir correct okay they're awesome in
there so what's this income jump you
went up to 135 back down to 95 what was
going on there
i went back full time as a nurse and it
just
not that like covid was a blessing by
any means but they were in dire need of
nurses
and so they were paying well and we made
the decision to put me back full-time
for to help us get out of wow yeah that
was one of them and then
we did a few other things
we sold we sold just about everything
the kids are basically all we
kept that's all you need at the end of
the day yeah oh that's that's right and
uh my i actually got several raises um
at work and then erin went to
prn which is just a a very limited
part-time because she wanted to go back
be back at home her her mom was battling
als at the time
and uh and she wanted to go back and be
with her so we we were willing to take
that pay cut going back down
yeah once you got free yeah for sure
yeah very cool
that's good well the good news about
nursing is you can jump in and you can
jump out and then jump back in i mean
you can do whatever you need to do and
that's
beauty of of her situation and you guys
just decided game on and knocked it out
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
um my my key in our key for it was i
have two
was get mad at it you have to get mad at
it
you you can't give up the fight you
can't get lazy you can't look at what
anybody else is doing you have to look
at your spouse or if you're single
look at yourself in the mirror and say
we we're going to do this and then the
second one which is even bigger is uh
prayer
both of those are really good ways to
get mad
yeah that's right
that's some of my some of my best prayer
time
yes yeah that's
my
my thing was that it was just finding
that why because we had the head
knowledge back from 10 years ago and it
that really wasn't enough for us and
until we got our why and that sick and
tired and just
mad at ourselves for what we've you know
the situation we put ourselves in well
and essentially in a sense what you
tolerated
yes sir correct and you just said and
and to aaron's point you have to reach
the emotions say i'm not going to
tolerate this anymore i'm not going to
tolerate this situation i'm going to
tolerate this behavior i'm going to
tolerate these products in my life
i'm going to tolerate life done this way
we're going to do it a different way and
when you reach that sick and tired of
being sick and tired that's a very good
point that when people finally say i've
had it that's when they changed their
lives that's good you guys are powerful
you're very cool
that's incredible how old are you two
i'm about i'm 32 and i'm 31 and you're
free how does it feel
oh
irreplaceable feeling yeah that was i
was able to take actually uh go on a
men's retreat the weekend after we got
debt-free and it was amazing it was the
first time i hadn't been stressed out
taking a trip my entire life
and we've been called to be givers and
god called us early in our marriage and
we just always like how are we gonna get
there
and now we see we see like okay we're
gonna be able to give like we've always
wanted wow
there you go that's big i love that i
love it
very well done you two very well done
we're proud of you great great job who
were your biggest cheerleaders outside
the two of you
well her dad and mom were very very
helpful thankful thankful that you're
going to do it since he made you go
through the class yeah that's right he's
been i mean he's just so proud that we
we did it and my folks helped help
helped us out as well and then
i've spent so many times calling uh
our fpu leader
dan and cynthia cool they they just they
blew it out of the park and they they
gave their story of how they worked the
baby steps and just the way they
presented it just it just blew my mind
and that was that was a big moment for
me to
to really kind of commit to this
all right well way to go guys we've got
a copy of baby steps millionaires for
you that's the next chapter in your
outrageously generous story that's where
you're going to be you're going to put
yourself in a position you can give away
numbers that you only used to dream of
owning and pretty good stuff how
ordinary people built extraordinary
wealth how you can too our number latest
number one best seller around here at
ramsey and uh send you a copy of total
money makeover for you to give and uh
disturb somebody's life with that and uh
give it away and mess with somebody a
little bit proud of you guys very very
well done logan and aaron in dallas
texas
119 000 paid off in 24 months making 58
she goes back to work up to 135 she
decides no more after i'm debt-free back
down to 95. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream all right we brought
lydia and gabby our kiddos with us and
they're gonna do it with us all right
y'all ready all right three
two
one
[Applause]
this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen
this is how it's done they even sound
adorable that's sweet
man
they are adorable we saw the youtube
pics for those of us that get to choose
cheat that way cute kiddos
oh that's fun young family changed their
whole family tree changed their future
they took control they're not waiting on
someone out of washington to fix their
life this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage
jennifer is here along with her
daughters mallory evelyn and julia
welcome guys good to have y'all thank
you honored to have you where do you all
live around houston texas okay cool
welcome to tennessee and all the way to
nashville to do a debt-free screen yes
sir i love it how much have you paid off
220 000
whoa how long did this take five years
five years and what was your range of
income during that time we started at
about a hundred and ended about 125.
okay cool what do you do for a living
i'm a special education teacher oh yeah
my husband was a an electronics
technician in the oil and gas industry
and he passed away in september oh my
what happened
um he was he had kidney cancer he was
diagnosed in 2017. whoa so five years of
fight huh
or four years um well yeah about two
yeah two and a half sorry i'm
getting the years myself yeah a few
years it was it was a long time it was a
long time yeah long fight yeah
and so the girls and you guys have been
uh as a family walking with him through
that whole thing yes and then the fight
was over and he had a graduation
ceremony in september
right right or is it september in the
fall
september yeah this past fall okay wow
i'm sorry yeah thank you sorry for what
y'all been through there's a lot of good
ways to get debt-free this is not one of
not what we planned no not the way you
want to do it we were on the road and uh
and then yeah we were able to finish it
with his um his insurance yeah so how
much life insurance was involved
um in the debt
no how much life insurance what did you
get oh we 465. good yeah how old was he
um 51. wow young yeah
wow okay
so you started the debt-free journey
five years ago
and two and a half to three years of it
you've also been fighting a cancer fight
right and actually actually we started
this is kind of my funny story our funny
story we started listening to you i
started listening to you back in 2007 so
we probably could have been standing on
this stage about five years ago
and
we i listened to your show i read the
total money makeover in about two days
went to my husband asked him you know if
he would if he would be interested in
doing this explain it to him and he was
on board except for putting the 401k
money away
and so i said okay well
let's try it and so we we we met with an
elp
um could i say his name on there okay
mark pickle in sugarland texas
and he was wonderful we did the
plastectomy cut off the cards and
and we spent the next couple of years
getting to get getting rid of that
credit card debt
and then we just kind of
fell off the wagon
we had some vw buses that we loved to go
camping in we
had two more babies uh right back to
back and um you know we just i went back
to school which we were supposed to be
that free before i did that but i went
back to school to become a teacher
and so uh yeah aft then fast forward to
2016
um when i got my degree i got a teaching
job and then we decided to just go full
on and by this time
dan was into doing it you know 401k and
everything doing the full plan so
yeah so that's when we we started
teaching i started or i started teaching
i worked for ubereats delivering
food and
we started off our gazelle intensity by
selling all of three of our buses
which was hard for us and um that's what
kind of got us going got the momentum
going so that's when you got serious
yeah yeah and then you start making
progress and so i'm guessing the 220
includes paying off the house
yes awesome wow what's the house worth
um right about two okay
talk about the um
the level of peace
that you have in a situation like this
where your 51 year old husband goes to
heaven
and you're sitting in a paid for house
with three teenage girls
um because of the planning that you all
had done to getting out of debt that
you've done and the fact you bought life
insurance yeah um i mean i don't think
you can overstate the difference in your
situation versus if that money wasn't i
i can't i can't even imagine if it had
been different
and uh and the funny thing is well not
funny but we looking back you know one
of the things that we kind of argued
about was why do we need insurance and
this was before we were following you
it's that extra 100 a month or 140 a
month
and um
but we were faithful about that and if
we didn't have it yeah we would be in a
much different situation yeah you would
have made it but it would have been a
lot tougher and right now you get you
have the uh
the financial room
to give you margin to just grieve yeah
without having to worry about bills
right and and that was the huge thing
i'm actually um i've been struggling
with with
mentally
and just trying to keep everything going
we we also lost my stepdad
and uh
with three months later so the girl's
grandfather and um it's just been a
rough time so i'm going to take a year
off yeah and i'm going to just be a mom
um and i'm i'm going to go back i love
teaching but and you can and i can right
right
give you the space to heal yeah that's
very real i'm so proud of you did you
guys have a good community that kind of
came around you during this time oh yeah
huge community um people from church
family friends co-workers i mean
the support has been huge emotionally
it's just um you know and i'm a
christian and i
um i know god's plan is we don't know
what god's plan is um but sometimes it's
just not fair yeah
exactly
yeah and and i know i have god's peace
in my heart yeah um and i know that i'll
get through this we'll get through this
um but
yeah it's still hard and you struggle
unbelievably hard
i'm so sorry
thank you
and simultaneously i'm so proud of him
and proud of you
uh for putting your lives together in
such a way that you can go through
something like this
and again give yourself the margin so we
usually ask people what the key to
getting out of debt is and um
you know in your case it's life
insurance we don't want to use this key
this is not the key you want to use
right not the process you want to use to
be to come to a free house and
everything to be baby step seven and
take a year off we won't do that for
other reasons and and go out to vw bus
you know right but oh my gosh yeah um so
but but in your case the
the key is um the the preparation that
you all had done by working the plan to
get out of debt and by making sure you
had the defenses the insurances in place
to take care of you and he yeah the com
i would say if he were standing here
with me um we were planning on being
here together because we were without
the life insurance we would have been at
this place in about a year and a half
and we uh communication was key because
we did have arguments before we didn't
we weren't um i mean not big arguments
but we just
once we started following the plan
uh once we started just really trusting
the plan and um and just i've listened
to you guys every day my kids um are
like do we have to listen to dave ramsey
again
i'm blaming girls i don't like listening
to me either they've seen
they've they've read all the junior
books growing up you know when they were
younger and so uh yeah it was uh
communication was key getting on the
same page
is essential and um
and just thinking about um
where we would be without it is scary
yeah well life insurance is one of those
ways you you say i love you to your
family and clearly your dad and your
husband he was that guy he wanted to
make sure his family was protected and
it's sad what happened but we're here to
celebrate with you guys and honor him
and we're just so proud of you thank you
pretty pretty amazing stuff well got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
and total money makeover and um those
really don't matter uh in this situation
you just read them and enjoy them or
give them away and
bless somebody with them um
now girls i know it's been the hardest
thing you'd ever imagine you could go
through
um but you know one thing you can always
stand on when you look back your mom and
dad are both absolute heroes
um
absolutely incredible powerful powerful
and your mom's stronger than she thinks
she is
right now she she's she's like a warrior
princess right now so she's good
well done y'all very well done
well done dan
good stuff all right it's jennifer
mallory evelyn julia and dan
a hundred or 220 000 paid off in five
years making 100 to 125. count it down
let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one we're done free
[Applause]
not the way you want to get there
but you know what this stuff works in
good times and in bed that's right this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today last week we launched the
first stop on our building wealth live
tour response has been incredible the
first event is not yet sold out but it's
getting close we'll be in orlando
florida may the 19th that's the first
one we're gonna be talking about the hot
topics of uh all the get-rich-quick
schemes that are going on out there and
then how to really get rich quick what
is the
fastest shortest quickest easiest way to
really become wealthy
and believe it or not it's not get rich
quick
who would have thought the energy in the
room when we taught this back in january
was over the top it was rachel cruz
george campbell that's beside me and i
and we did this building wealth live
event
here in nashville it sold out in 20
minutes on that one this one in orlando
is like i said it's over half sold out
it's been on sale for like uh eight days
or five days or something uh dr john
dolone and ken coleman are coming with
us and uh they're gonna have some
sessions as well so this is a great
bargain tickets are only 25 you can get
a four pack so bring another couple
bring some friends of yours bring your
parents bring your grown kids and
whatever
yeah you get a four pack for 60 bucks
wow it's kind of a bogo type of a thing
this great deal so again limited amount
of tickets left in orlando already
selling out we're going to announce
other cities coming soon the building
wealth live tour george it's going to be
fun i can't wait we had a great time
here locally and i just i'm pumped to go
out on the road and go somewhere see
some real people ah real imagination
real people in a real auditorium and for
15 bucks that's cheaper than a movie
guys come on 25 15 if you do a four pack
bring some friends that really that's a
great
dot
deal
slash events and we'll get you all set
up richard is with us in tampa hi
richard welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay i have a quick relationship
question i'm trying to convince my wife
that we are ready to have children
but she keeps bringing up excuses i
don't know if they're excuses but
she says she doesn't have a career yet
and that i'm not stable at my job
because i change jobs
roughly every three years
so my question is how do i convince her
that we are ready to have children from
a financial standpoint
how long you been married
we've been married for
three and a half years now okay well
george just got his second french
bulldog which is more expensive than
children and i'll tell you
it is uh it's everything you thought it
would be
but richard
here's the thing you said you changed
job every three years what are you doing
for work
i am an
i.t audit manager so i'm in consulting
okay what do you make
right now i just got a race and i'm
making a 130 000 a year okay
all right this has nothing to do with
financial and nothing to do with your
income
uh she has some other reason that she
doesn't have kids
and she's using a a a
a smoke screen because people that make
135 000 a year can afford to have kids
okay i mean that's just that's kind of
that's mathematically
just simply not true
okay and you change jobs every three
years you're not exactly unstable you
didn't change job three times in three
months you changed up three times
in your career and she hasn't started
her career i mean when are you when
you're gonna start it i mean you don't
have to start a career you can do
whatever if you don't have kids there's
one thing you don't no no one's
requiring people to have babies but you
guys make enough money to have babies
so and she knows that
i mean if you told me you're making 13
000 a year i mean we'd have a discussion
here dude about your job
and you know as a provider and so forth
but you make 135 000 a year you can
afford to have kids
a lot of them really i agree and throw
in a french bulldog i mean you'll be all
right just for fun yeah but then you
asked her about her fears around this i
mean beyond just money
does she think that kids are just really
expensive and that it's gonna tamper the
budget
yeah i think there are some
there are some other reasons
uh
so she thinks like healthcare is really
expensive like through my job it's like
10 000 a year to have both myself
covered and
to have both of us on on the health
insurance and she thinks like having a
baby it's going to be
thousands of dollars so she's scared
about that yeah how long y'all been
married
uh
three and a half going on four right now
okay how old are you
i'm 35 so i'm getting up there that's
why how old is
she she is 30 right now okay and um how
many brothers and sisters did you have
and how many brothers and sisters does
she have
so i am the youngest of five brothers
and sisters and she is
the second of four
brothers and sisters
both of you had lots of siblings
so um yeah one
you know so i i don't know what's going
on um
i'll i'll just answer this as the old
grandpa of the group um
with seven grand babies babies are the
best thing that happened to anyone as
far as i'm concerned they're the best
things ever happened to me the only
thing that's better than babies is
grandbabies
and if i don't know how great grand
babies are going to be i've been nicer
to their parents but the um
uh so you know
but but
and no amount of health care or whatever
you're making 135 000 you're 30 years
old if you're gonna have kids you'll
need to get with it
um
you're already
you're already late it's time to get
rocking here and so um you know i think
if i think she's not um
she may not even personally realize
why she's really afraid but it's not
money
it's not the finances
something else is worrying her something
else is holding her back and i don't
know what it is and i think you guys
ought to sit down with a good marriage
counselor and not because i think your
marriage is in trouble but to get a good
tune-up sometimes you need a referee to
throw a flag
you know and go okay because if you were
if the two of you were just sitting with
me at dinner and you were like friends
of ours or you would be like kids of
friends of ours or something like that
um i i would just go
all right i'm calling bs
that's not what it is what's really
going on
and she would go no no no no no i'm
still calling bs because you're lying it
god makes 135 000 a year you're 30 years
old if you're gonna have babies ever
now's the time
800 is health care welcome to obamacare
i mean it's what it costs this is what
you signed up for when you voted for him
so here we go and so you know this is
the deal
and uh boom and you know so decide now
what's really going on what are you
really afraid of because she's really
afraid of something and i don't know
what it is but i would just be grandpa
and you can't do that from the husband
position it doesn't work i mean you can
show her on paper on the budget
we're going to be okay there's no sense
in arguing a smoke screen objection this
is not the real objection
because it's not it's so far off
it's so such a slam dunk
that you can afford to have kids
if anybody i've talked to this week can
afford to have kids it's you there's
people way bro
freaking six figures i mean you know how
long it was before we made six figures
and we tell people if you're in debt
it's okay to have kids you don't need to
wait i thought you were gonna tell me
all the ways you were broke or something
but um no you're there's something else
going on dude and so i don't know how to
coach you other than to say get a coach
in the room with you that's somebody
that both of you can trust to look at
you and to draw those fears out and
allay those fears or deal with them
something else makes her feel
uh vulnerable
she feels insecure
and vulnerable and she's blaming it on
the money but it's not money there's
something else going on
it may be the way you treat her it may
be your temper it may be i don't know i
don't have any idea what's going on but
something makes her feel vulnerable that
she doesn't
feel safe and she because
for ladies money often is a safety
language
it's a language of safety security big
pile of money lots of safety no money no
safety you know but here we got a big
pile of money and yet we don't feel safe
so something else is going on
and uh that's my
uh two dollar insight it was probably
worth what you paid for it but um
you know this thing
he's very wise to ask the question
because this
money stuff is so tied to relationships
and it's so tied to our dreams and our
fears and our visions that when we can't
get aligned on it then then we know
something's going on yeah and there
could be something outside of just their
relationship where there's an insecurity
there or a fear about this big life
change happening and so i think
unpacking that with a third party that
could be really helpful yeah yeah and
it's not to say you have to have
children it's not required um i i i'm a
big fan of it but it's not to say you
have to
you you can i choose to not do that and
i love you just as much and help you
just as much
and not say you're afraid of something
but just go i choose not to that's okay
too
that puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the box
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host george campbell
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life and your money it's a free call at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five we'll talk about relationships
mental health we'll talk about jobs and
careers we'll talk about money we'll
talk about wealth we'll talk about
whatever you want to talk about it's
your life and it's right here on the
ramsey show
elizabeth is going to start off this
hour she's in washington d.c hi
elizabeth how are you
hi dave i'm doing well how are you
better than i deserve what's up
awesome so my husband and i we're on
baby steps four and six um we live in dc
but we're currently renting and we own a
property in atlanta so the current
tenants that i have the release ends
actually on april 1st and so i'm trying
to decide whether we should spend 2500
for a property manager to bring in a new
tenant or if we should just go ahead and
sell the house sell it
sell it
okay
i love rental property i hate long
distance rental property
right and you did not buy this house as
a rental property you used to live there
and you moved to dc and kept it
yes you're a landlord by default not by
strategy
right
yeah what would you get if you sold it
um so
um the realtor is actually going to list
it for 285 and there's about 158 left on
it okay
sorry yeah what would you do with the
with the profits
so um we would just buy a new house
probably in dc or just kind of hold off
for maybe two years and decide where we
want to be
whether it's like closer to family but
we we have agreed that we don't want to
go back to atlanta okay now there's no
reason to keep this house
a lot of reasons
okay and i have one more question so
um when it comes to long-distance um
rental properties when we get to that
point what would you consider
um too far to to be a landlord can i
drive to it
easy i mean like i don't have any rental
properties that are more
than an hour apart
okay gotcha they're all they're all
within 30 minutes of where i sit right
here but from one of them the furthest
away to the other one it might take an
hour but
um that would be with traffic but yeah i
mean
i don't i mean i personally i'll drive
by them once or twice a year but our
management team i've got my own in-house
property management because i own a lot
of property but uh they you know do
quarterly inspections
um they uh are are constantly checking
the property and you just don't you
can't keep your hands around it property
requires
a level of effort in order to keep it up
in order to keep it from getting
destroyed in order to
you know suddenly there's something
happening over there with a tenant and
you went what i got 17 cats what you
know and so um
you know they're cat hoarders who knew
but yeah so
people do stuff and so um and that'll
destroy a house yeah so it's just you
get the the actual
practical fact of landlording and just
being in proximity to it you will do a
much better job even if you're using a
property manager you'll do a much better
job if it's in the vicinity because you
know you and your husband out to eat and
you just say nah i'm gonna drive down
that street just wonder what's over
there oh that's the house we own yeah
and uh yeah we're gonna look at it and
just uh get a feel for what's going on i
drove by one of ours the other day and
the bushes they really need to be done
and i just like do you have your
trimmers out there just
i didn't jump out of the car with my
pocket knife but no but the uh
but yeah i did i did place an order for
that to be fixed when i got back oh good
got it back on the email but i mean
that's you know you just gotta it's like
a long distance relationship i wouldn't
choose one if i could and so don't do
that with your rental property
it's not fun
it's not fun good analogy all right
diane's in oklahoma city hi diane how
are you
hi dave thank you for taking my call
sure what's up
well my question is how to best put
approximately 183 000 that i have in a
bank account to work for my retirement
i've never owned my own home and i
thought about investing in a small condo
i currently rent a condo for 900 a month
a little less than a thousand with bills
included
okay
now that oklahoma accents coming through
where are you
from oh
everything no
uh australia or england which is it i'm
having trouble picking it up
england okay all right good well welcome
to oklahoma city it's a wonderful place
i'll be over there in a couple of weeks
hanging out with my friend craig
groeschel all right the uh
hey yeah yeah
are you going to be there a while
i plan to be yes
okay
um if you're going to be there three
years or more i would take that money
and buy a condo for cash
okay that you're going to live in you
could pay cash for a condo for that
couldn't you
absolutely i was hoping to just spend a
little over a hundred thousand for one
and then possibly put that the other
somewhere else and i need your
suggestions on that i know you really
like mutual funds so what's your
recommendation i have a small business
and i'm going to begin a
step this year i also started my first
growth ira last year and i plan to do
another one soon
um
but i i know you're big on mutual funds
what would you recommend i do with the
remainder yeah i mean you can definitely
i'd max out your retirement accounts
first and then if you've maxed those out
and there's nowhere else to go you can
put those in taxable accounts and you
can do index funds and mutual funds in
there to let that money grow for you
yeah just keep it simple it doesn't have
to be complicated okay an s p 500 index
fund is where i park a lot of mine after
i've maxed out everything else
and you got a paid for property you're
sitting on what we call baby step seven
uh so everything's 100 debt free you've
got some money left over to invest
you're going to max out your sep max out
your roth um and in mutual funds and
then in addition to that i would just
use an s p 500 index fund what georgia
is saying so georgia's exactly now make
sure you've got your emergency fund
intact and keep that separate from all
this money yup uh talia is with us in
portland oregon is italia did i
pronounce that correctly
uh yes you did hi how are you better
than i deserve how can we help
okay so i have a question i feel like
your advice would usually be to don't do
it so i need to confirm with you to
either do it or not do it so
um a little background i have 47 000 in
student loans
and 20 000 in retirement it's
15 000 and a 403 b 5k in a roth ira
and i make 90 000 a year as a nurse i
have no other student debt
so i would never cash out this
retirement but i've had people suggest
it and they're like just call dave and
see what he would say twenty 000
isn't a lot but then i know there's like
the penalty and all that so
i just kind of want to know like yes the
advice still stands don't do it
you know i wish i could say you're
special today but you're not don't do it
you're going to rob from your future and
you don't need to do that you have a
great income and this is a shortcut and
it's not going to lead you to somewhere
worth going when you have to pay this
thing back and you rob from all the
growth when you when you cash it out
you're going to have a 10 penalty plus
your tax rate and you're sitting at
about a 25 bracket and so you're you're
borrowing money at 35 interest
to pay off student loan debt no that's
what i thought you might say yeah i'm
fairly predictable because i say the
same thing over and over again and
people still listen it's just come on
shock us
but now i don't know who told you to
call me because
they obviously don't listen enough to
know i say the same thing over and over
again i hope i say it over and over
again so much george says it yeah there
you go you call me a parrot for that
reason whoa there we go there you go
well you're my favorite parrot oh
that's so sweet you're mine too dude
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsay to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Applause]
well obviously the pandemic was a tough
time for employers and employees
the past couple of years has changed a
lot for a lot of people and it hasn't
stopped with a great resignation
inflation
everything else going on workers are
burning out left and right employers
need to know how to help their stressed
out team members so they don't lose
heart
our employee wellness team smart dollar
just did a study that found out more
than half of american employees
worry
about their personal finances
every day
55 percent to be exact and
three-quarters of them wish their
employer provided more resources to help
them manage their money better
so if you're a business owner an hr
leader you need to check out this new
research
the 2022 smart dollar employee benefits
study looks at everything employees and
their financial health their mental
health in the workplace whether or not
they're getting ready to quit on you
if you're interested in keeping the good
employees you have you need to know this
and you need to read it like right now
you can find the study for free
at ramsey solutions dot com smart dollar
2022
study
ramsey solutions dot com smart dollar
2022
study and you can download it for free
our question of the day comes from
blinds.com
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
even if you mismeasure you pick the
wrong color they'll remake your window
blinds for free free samples free
shipping and the new promos all the time
man you'll save even more always use the
code name the promo code ramsey to get
the best deal it's magic use the promo
code ramsay
today's question comes from mark in
missouri he said i know you hate reverse
mortgages but my question is this i'm 57
and my wife is 32. we have no kids i was
thinking of getting a reverse mortgage
to enjoy my money while i can let's say
i live another 20 years then my wife
inherits the house and lives there the
rest of her life why shouldn't i get a
reverse mortgage
man
well because market's not gonna work
like you think it's going to work
you just picked up the high points that
the sales job gave you and you didn't
get the reality
the reality is the interest rates that
the reverse mortgages are calculated on
are almost double what traditional
interest rates are on a mortgage
the fees
are more than double
when you go to close on the reverse
mortgage they get you coming
they get you going
and the foreclosure rate on reverse
mortgages is tenfold
the national average for traditional
mortgages wait wait wait wait wait
they're paying me how could i get
foreclosed on
and then when they run out of equity by
the way it's only 65 of the equity that
you can take out
up to 65 loan to value and when you run
out of the equity then you still have to
maintain the property
even though you have no money you have
to keep the property taxes paid the
insurance paid and the maintenance done
if you don't do any one of the three the
clauses in the document allow them to
foreclose because the collateral is
falling apart or getting foreclosed on
for lack of insurance or lack of
taxes paid and so we're finding poor
little widows like you're going to leave
behind who entered into these things are
now losing their homes at four and five
and six times the rate that you lose at
home in a traditional mortgage
dude you're trying to skin a cat the
wrong way this is not how you become
wealthy the way you become wealthy and
make sure she's secure is you get the
house paid off and then you save up some
money and you live like no one else so
later you can live like no one else
beautifully said so the simple answer is
if paying off your house is the best
option then going into the reverse side
and borrowing against your house is the
worst option and it's gonna leave his
wife in a lurch here because she's gonna
have to pay the full thing off if if he
dies before it's sold with all the
interest or she surrenders it to the
bank well now if it's in both her name
she'll be able to sit there in it until
until something happens but a lot of
these have call provisions in them i got
to tell you it's a filthy business and i
would stay away from it
and it's bad products the product design
is not good for you and they go after
all older folk i mean that's their
target demo with these yeah see the
commercials late at night exactly
exactly so that's another thing you can
think about is this okay
if your investment product or financial
product
is advertised
on a cable channel
right next to snuggies and walk-in
bathtubs
you probably don't want to do it now
snuggy is a good investment let's be
clear
oh i'm just saying if that's where your
financials so you can just line up what
gold coins uh you can line up reverse
mortgages with washed up actors
um you can you know you know we got the
funds and we got magnum p tom
yeah and uh and so you know it's
old-time stuff and so these guys are i'm
sure they're great guys they're just
bought and paid for but i'm not mad at
tom or henry but um love to meet either
one of them but i'm not buying the crap
and the the little company that tom
endorses they had an 800 million dollar
fine wow
that's scary yeah that's some shady
business right there that's some shady
business so let's not do that scott's
with us in new york city hey scott how
are you
well dave and yourself better than i
deserve how can i help
good good
i'll start with my question and then
give a little background if i can
my wife and i are 42 years old we we own
a vacation property which is actually
only four miles away from our main house
it's a it's a waterfront property
uh that we rent a little bit just to
cover its overall cost i own this
property outright and i'm curious if i
should sell it
to pay my main house off
uh so the house the house we live in
right now i have a 870 000 mortgage on
it it's worth about a million for
uh the house that we're looking to sell
is actually got a value of about three
million right now
um but i have
uh i i would have substantial capital
gains because of the real estate market
in the last two or three years here wow
so your lake house is worth more than
your house
well considerably it is yeah it is
that's fun i like that uh
that's a style that's styling right it
really is a blessing so why don't you
just move in the lake house
uh it's it is a seasonal it's a seasonal
house what a front house it is seasonal
uh and i also have my parents my elderly
parents that live with us so we we need
a little more room to uh to be able to
accommodate them as well
um we've got substantial wealth which
gives you a lot of options what other
money do you have whatever the money do
you have that we could just get your
mortgage paid off and keep it
yeah so
i make about 170 000 a year
uh i am self-employed it fluctuates you
have any money saved that is not
retirement money other than these
properties
i don't i have no debt no car payments
no nothing uh but no cash on hand very
very little five six thousand dollars
yeah uh so you got a seven year eight
year journey to pay this house off if
you keep the if you keep the lake house
absolutely absolutely and i got a kid
that's just heading off to college this
year i got
a 14 and 13 year old behind that one
that's going to be heading off to
college but i typically you know i'm set
up to cash flow those those colleges
okay are you pretty tight financially
with that eight hundred seventy thousand
dollar mortgage
i i am since cole that i am uh typically
no i've been very you know been fined a
lot of cash flowing uh but since cove
and i'm in the construction business and
we're busy as all heck
but the contracts
we were lucky to be very flush but we've
had contracts that you know are six
seven months old and then it takes a
year to build these custom homes
and with cost increases
really really got out of hand yeah
really got out of hand so
yeah so it is it is a little tight right
now
well there's not a wrong there's not a
wrong answer if it gives you more joy
and more peace
to dump the lake house and be 100 dead
free and have a pile of cash during this
tight time um that's fine um
if you just would you know
if you feel would feel stupid for doing
that then don't do it i mean you can you
can probably hang on without any trouble
and get your house paid off over a
period of years and hang on to the house
it is it is you know it's weird that
your lake house a few miles from you
is worth three times what your house is
it's just a little strange in your
portfolio but it's not the end of the
world
um i'm
i love my lake house i'm not selling it
so you can do whatever you want to do
but um
in your case
uh
you're asking the question which makes
me kind of think you
may want to do it but it's up to you you
don't have a financial reason driving
this one way or the other it's personal
call
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get 1 000 to 2500
off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones as we talk
about your life and your money triple
eight eight two five five two two five
reuben is with us in green bay wisconsin
hi reuben welcome to the ramsay show
hi mr ramsey how are you doing today
better than i deserve sir how can i help
fantastic uh so yeah first my question
and then i'll fill in a couple blanks uh
i am getting ready to uh go into a new
field um
it's life insurance i'm getting ready to
take my state exam i've been studying
for the last uh month
um
and this is final expense insurance and
i recently heard on one of your shows
you kind of had spoken against whole
life insurance this is really
a brand new um
landscape for me so i really don't have
a lot of frame of reference i guess i
just want to make sure i'm um
getting into something that's
you know noteworthy and you know going
to uh to be something i can stand behind
uh the insurance company i'm getting
ready to pair with is called lincoln
heritage so um
that is uh that's kind of what's going
on currently just a little background
like on the personal
um
i'm 44 just turned 44.
i am
on my
just over two years clean from a 20-year
heroin addiction wow definitely
definitely a late bloomer here um
i
had a dependency issue with chemicals
for a long time uh jail's institution
and then finally death
uh i was revived i ended up going into a
faith-based
recovery program and
until he got healed set free
and uh jesus is my lord and savior thank
you lord second second chance in life i
really feel and i just wanna
you know i'm trying to um
this it's more than just about money to
me it's about
breaking generational things i've got
children i just have
so much uh to be thankful for so much
writing on on all of this um i have a
great church i've been plugged into and
uh
they um they were the ones that first
you know exposed me to
your podcast into baby steps um
actually i lost my uh my job
right before christmas um what were you
doing and
i was actually selling for uh budget
blinds
um so you're you're a people person
i love yeah i love it
yeah going into people's house and just
kind of connecting with them sometimes i
really felt like the secondary reason i
was there is to help them with window
treatments or whatever but yeah it was
definitely fulfilling and well you're a
hero reuben man i'm proud of you way to
go um so let's do it let's do a couple
of things um
uh
this is a decision you have to make you
don't make it because i said to you've
got to gather facts but you're calling
me and saying
uh it bothered you that i tell people
not to buy whole life and you're signed
up to become a salesman for it so that's
throwing you off
um well i guess it's industrial life
right because it's final expense
insurance so i don't know if it's one in
the same i have no idea
i mean i i do have an idea in that i'm
studying i understand that whole life is
different than industrial and so you
know
does the insurance that you're selling
have a cash value
uh it does okay then it's a type of
whole life or cash value product there
there are various types i mean there's
uh universal life there's variable life
there's whole lot there's industrial i
mean but anything that has a cash value
in it is where i'm going to have a
problem okay
okay um and i i'm not going to end this
call
i i think you're an amazing man and i
don't want to end this call trash your
dreams of
what you're going for for your career
but i'm going to give you a whole bunch
of stuff to work on and decide for
yourself number one i'm going to give
you a copy of ken coleman's new book
from paycheck to purpose because that's
the move you're trying to make you're
trying to get into something that has
meaning and purpose because your life
has a
a whole fresh start you're seeing things
with cleaner eyes than you have ever
seen because of your journey and it's a
wonderful place in your journey that you
are and we want to assist you in that
and uh so that book is in case i talk
you into quitting before you start
okay okay uh so the the product uh the
reason i don't like the product is this
the way it works mathematically
is not a good deal for the person that
buys it
and i'll explain it to you okay whole
life traditional cash value insurance
is
20 times
more expensive for the same amount
of coverage of life insurance and so
let's say you were going to buy a
a a
200 000 policy
if it was a hundred dollars a month for
whole life
it would be five dollars a month for
term insurance
right okay
now
where does the other 95 dollars go well
it goes to build up this cash
value
inside the policy
it's a savings account inside the policy
in and of itself that's not a bad
problem except that the fees are
ridiculous in the whole life world now i
don't know the particular product you're
selling but the
typical whole life policy the first
three years your cash value build up is
zero
which means they kept your 95 dollars a
month that you put in a savings account
it was zero
upfront fees okay
the second thing is the rate at which
the money accrues is somewhere around
1.2 percent according to federal trade
commission studies
the rate of return on your savings
account sucks
as a long-term investment and this is a
long-term play
and the third problem is this
when you die after paying 95
extra per month
five dollars bought the insurance
and you're paying 95 extra for savings
they pay
the face value of the policy in this
case 200 000
so if you've built up after you got
through the three zero years and you got
a horrible rate of return and you keep
putting 95 in there and you built up 20
000 in cash value and you die
they send your beneficiary your spouse
probably 200 000 bucks what happens to
your 20 000 savings account that sucked
they keep it
and so this is like going down to the
bank and opening a savings account that
the first three years you put money in
it they keep your money after that they
give you a lousy rate of return and when
you when you die they keep your money
it's a horrible way to save money
and so consequently the people that
you're talking about going to work for
hate me
with a vengeance because i tell people
not to buy what they sell every day and
have for 30 years
um the worst the the particular product
that you're in or that company i'm not
even familiar with but i'll guarantee
you that their face is going to turn
inside out and explode when you just
mention the name dave ramsey so don't
mention it because it won't do any good
we don't want anybody's head exploding
we're not going to make friends like
that yeah it's not if you're going to
quit just quit be do it with class you
don't have to go in there and try to
change them you're not going to change
them they're going to keep doing it
they've been doing it for 100 years
so
lastly what i'll do so that you can
review this material
in detail is i want to sign you up for
ramsey plus which is the financial peace
university class and every dollar app
in that class there is an insurance
lesson that goes into detail
on the life insurance portion so you can
learn in detail what we teach about life
insurance and i you can't dispute it
because it's just math it's a fact
and so um
consequently
no financial planning people unless
they're in the insurance business and
call themselves financial planners no
one in the financial world pushes cash
value life insurance anywhere unless
they sell it
there's no independent financial people
that push the stuff they all say buy the
term insurance for five dollars instead
of the cash value for 100 do your
investing with your 95 difference
anywhere else but inside of a cash value
policy you're better off putting it in a
fruit jar in the backyard at least the
family can find it and it's there when
you die they don't keep it yeah it's
trying to be investing and insurance at
the same time and it's it's terrible at
both at the end of the day so if i'm
selling this thing i'm going to have a
moral problem knowing how much i know so
he's ignorance was bliss until now
reuben just learned a little too much
about whole life i think he can find a
better job out there if he loves sales
if he even loves insurance that's a
noble thing to sell but not whole life i
would stay away and these companies are
like a northwestern you know it's it's
your buddies from college that want to
make a big commission off you yeah stay
away yeah it's uh
again i
i tell you never to buy it and so and i
know i'm kind of bursting your bubble in
the middle of you having this whole
recovery journey and everything and i i
don't want to do that i want to say
you're a hero i'm proud of you you and i
are going to be friends even if you
decide to work there so i'm just you
stay with it buddy but um
hang on kelly i'll get you the book for
ken coleman and we'll get you signed up
for ramsey plus i'm not charging you a
thing for any of this and i'm not going
to keep your money when you die
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today psalm 94 19 when
anxiety was great within me your
consolation brought me joy
mark twain said a man cannot be
comfortable
without his own approval
that's pretty strong
that'll do george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today tj is
with us in lima ohio hi tj how are you
good thanks dave and george thanks for
taking my call sure what's up
yeah so i got a question about whether
or not i should pay off the remainder of
my car this month or wait until
next month so i'll give you the
situation in brief first i want to thank
you guys uh when i started this process
about 14 months ago i was making 45 000
a year within two months i started
making 60 000 a year and just today i
just got an offer to make a hundred
thousand dollars starting next month wow
good for you i paid
yeah good day man that's killer 28
yeah i'm really excited i'm a little
shaky to be honest with you i
paid off 28 000 in the last 12 months
and
i
this week i'll be able to have the funds
to pay the remainder of the car off
which is 2 638
um now
the question that i have is
if i pay off the car this month i'll be
making next month a little tight
financially until i get my first
paycheck at my new job so the question
boils down to do i go ahead and pay the
car off or is it okay to dip into the
emergency fund as a gap bill now i'm
kind of conservative so i think
i should pay off the majority of it and
then pay the remainder after i've
secured that first paycheck and my wife
thinks i it's okay to dip into that
emergency fund so i'd like to hear your
thoughts
what's your car payment
it is
twenty four 408.24
a month
but like i said uh how much money you
have in your emergency fund
a thousand dollars okay just making sure
you're doing this right because you're
acting like there's a lot of money and
on top of that you'll be able to pay off
the car but you'll have a thousand
dollars to your name for a short period
of time
correct so i don't understand why you're
gonna i don't understand why you're
gonna miss a paycheck changing jobs
well i don't anticipate that i will but
you know there might be a like this job
right now pays weekly and i don't know
if the next job will pay
bi-weekly or you know
semi-monthly whatever
but i didn't know if if i should pause
just as a security blanket or just go
forth and assume the best i guess
does your wife work outside the home
no my wife is a stay-at-home mom with
our two little girls and she actually
watches two kids to you know to help
with income as well
[Music]
what does she make doing that
uh right at
two thousand dollars a month um mostly
she uses her income to pay for food
household supplies things of that nature
and we're really using my income to
tackle large bills uh like the mortgage
the car payments uh the debts and then
also attack the debt pretty heavily
don't you so
your conservative nature is what's
making you assume that you're going to
dip into the emergency fund we don't
really know that you're going to have to
because you really don't know how the
new place is structured yet
correct
so let's find that information before we
make the decision
okay
so i you know let's pretend there's no
change that you go from one paycheck to
another
then you would have just paid off the
car now right
right but let's change let's pretend
there's a two thousand dollar gap
between the time you get paid and now
all right
and the change over and you only have
one thousand dollars well then having
paid off the car would have been silly
because your kid's gonna be hungry
right
so we need to work from facts on this uh
as to what's really going on but i i
think that's what's going to happen i
mean a normal transition would be
you you
we we pay in america generally speaking
uh for the work that is completed
in other words you work and you get paid
at the end of the work time you work and
then you get paid then the work time and
so if you work and you get your final
paycheck and the next week you go to
work at the other place and it's two
weeks and you get a paycheck
you're not gonna miss a check
you're gonna miss a weekly hit but
you're gonna have two weeks of pay if
you can sit down look at that and go
well with my wife with keeping the kids
with that income we're easy it's no
problem i think that's probably what's
going to happen
unless there's a start date that's
pushed out on the new place after you
leave the old place now you could leave
a gap in the middle there right
right but i mean i think we need to
figure out exactly where you are ask the
employer hey when is that first check
going to come in for planning purposes
and yeah we plan from that but you're
not going to have a car payment either
so you're going to need less money yeah
once the car is paid it's only 400 bucks
swing but you know so it's not a 2600
swing it's 2200 swing but and we got 2
000 coming in from her a thousand
sitting in the account i just i think
you're going to be okay but i don't want
your kid to be hungry but also don't
want you making decisions that are just
based on the fact that oh i'm kind of
conservative
no we get the car paid off you know okay
if you're conservative or not but um but
let's but but let your conservative
cautious turn into wisdom and say we're
gonna gather this information from the
new employer match it with the old
employer pay and and here's the gap or
there is no gap and then you can make
your decision and we're going to live
like we did not get a raise because we
have an emergency fund to build up as
soon as this debt's paid off yeah yeah
just keep plowing on through keep
working your baby steps for sure so well
done jenna's with us in wisconsin hi
jenna how are you
hey god how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
hey um i was just curious is it wise for
my husband to quit his public work job
in order to continue
an already in business working cabinet
making company
especially with concern for the future
and market and the current economy cost
yes
he should go be self-employed
i should prefer this by saying we are a
baby step number two so far we have paid
off 210 000 with 55 left to go way to go
that's awesome
i'm assuming he's going to make more
though you're assuming he's going to
make less
which one of us was right
well i think
there's security in with the public
works job as far as no there's nothing
it's 47. there's not some coop over
there has to make payroll
security in the workplace is mythology
what's he making his current job
so his current job in the public
workshop he makes forty seven thousand a
year um
what do you make last year on the
cabinets
and then last year his net profit was 40
000. but that wasn't full-time i can't
yeah that was just part time so he's
going to do better if he just increases
his time spent on the cabinet business
it sounds like he's not scared of work
either so i feel pretty good about
security of him being self-employed
sure yeah and i and yeah and the other
thing is i was trying to
you know for the future like this fall
if all of the interest rates go up um i
guess i was just kind of nervous that
way he's gonna double his income
yeah he's gonna double his income
you can make a hundred thousand dollars
next year
sure i mean we do have forty thousand
dollars of face frames and lumber
sitting in our garage because of orders
so
yes i don't doubt that um
i guess yeah i think you can clear six
figures with this new business and get
you guys out of debt even faster
sure yeah
so jenna we're big believers in
self-employment when you've got a real
gig going this guy's got a real gig
going
and what i don't want you to do is i
don't want you to confuse i don't want
you to say i'm willing for my husband to
make half as much
working for the city as he can make
working on his own
and call that security
that's not security
now the city's probably not going to go
broke they're probably going to keep
paying him they may not lay everybody
off
but they might too they have before it
wouldn't be the first time that the city
had a layoff
and so you know but don't make half as
much as you can make in the marketplace
and call that security just because
somebody else is writing your paycheck
his ability to get up leave the cave and
kill something and drag it home has been
proven
that's true he's a smart guy and he's a
hard worker now i do want you guys to
want to coach up i'm going to send you a
copy of the book entre leadership
because i think this guy's really good
at making cabinets his next step is to
learn how to run a business
it's a different skill than making
cabinets
and if you're gonna be bringing in net
profit of a hundred grand a year you
gotta run the business and so he needs
to get into that i'll send you a copy of
our book how we run ours it's called
entree leadership thank you for calling
in george good show good stuff thanks
dave that puts us hour the ramsey show
in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free screen live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you